Film Courage: Going back to curiosity, which
is more crucial [to you as filmmakers]?
An interesting topic but a reluctant or not
so fully developed subject (for whatever reason)?
Or the reverse, a fascinating person but a
topic that is more vague and little bit too
broad?
Heidi Ewing: Well, we don’t make films about
topics.
We’re very careful not to come up with a
topic and then try to back into it.
But it’s important to have subject matter
that is rich and has depth, that it could
be full of surprises and twists and turns,
but it doesn’t matter if you have that in-depth
topic if you don’t have amazing characters
to take you on the journey.
So really we look for both.
We look for subject matter that hasn’t been
picked over so many times that people think
that they know that much about it.
And you also need these great storytellers,
which is part of our casting process, to find
those who can articulate a journey or can
change over the course of a film and bring
a subject matter to life.
Rachel Grady: I think it would be almost a
Venn diagram actually when you put it that
way.
Which is, if there are both, we make a movie
about it.
And it’s hard to have both.
It’s unusual, which is why we make a film
every couple of years or so because they don’t
come along every minute.
Film Courage: How far into the process of
the film do you know if the subject working?
I know Heidi you’d talked previously about
with [their film] The Boys of Baraka that
you had one subject that seemed more reluctant
but that person appeared so fascinating that
you really wanted to keep up with it [the
filming].
Heidi Ewing: Yeah…it was a mistake.
Film Courage: Okay…and I’m sure that was
a painful mistake because I’m sure you really
wanted that person in the film?
Heidi Ewing: Very much, Dewon.
The one the got away.
We have learned over a long career that reluctant
subjects are no subjects at all.
A reluctant subject only exists in your mind.
He or she will never participate or allow
you the access that we need in order to make
a satisfying film.
So we detect very early on by doing test shoots
and allowing people to say “Listen, let’s
come into your house, let’s shoot a little
and see how it feels for both of us?”
Because a reluctant or a subject that is too
shy or camera shy or too self-conscious probably
won’t get over that and so you have to move
on.
And it can be very, very painful and we don’t
really make that mistake too much anymore.
On this film [ONE OF US documentary] we did
film several people before we settled on our
final three and one was a reluctant subject
that we spent a couple, too many days on (maybe)
thinking that he might come around but he
did not.
So you keep making those stumbles.
Hopefully you spend less and less time on
the reluctant subject every film.